جدل عراقي يثار بعد انطلاق منصه بلغ
التابعه لوزاره الداخليه العراقيه مستهدفه
صانعي ما يسيء للذوق العام وفقا لاحكام
الماده
430 من قانون العقوبات واعلنت هذه المنصه
عن ان هنالك سته مدانين حتى الان بتهمه
الاساءه لذوق العام بينما يخضع ثمانيه
اخرون للتحقيق
[موسيقى]
تهمه مجهوله المعايير هكذا وصفها اغلب
النشطاء على مواقع التواصل فلم تفسر
الجهات الامنيه ولا القضائيه ماذا يعني
المحتوى الهابط وفق القانون العراقي وهل
سيشمل القرار اصحاب المحتوى السياسي من
البرلمانيين مثلا على كل حال هذا القرار
وجها انتقادات كثيره من المواطنين كما
سنرى
اي شيء اشوفه بنظر انه هو محتوى هابط ممكن
ابلغ عليه ماكو معايير للمحتوى الهابط
يعني مثلا هذا هي المحتويات الهابطه او
الاشخاص اللي انشالوا اللي اعتقلوهم على
مود المحتوى الهابط زين هم بالبدايه
المجتمع مو كان متقبلهم لو المجتمع ما
تقبلهم ما اشتغلوا هاي الشهره وصارت لهم
طشه ومشاهداتهم عبره الملايين يعني خوفش
من تتحول هاي القضيه الى يعني تقييد لحريه
الناس بالتعبير عن النفس وتكون العقوبات
تتوافق مع حجم المشكله يعني مبدئيا نعرف
كل الحياه تحتاج تدري انا شوف الاجراءات
اللي صدرت بحق صناع المحتوى هي اجراءات قد
تكون او قد اسميها تعسفيه
الجدل مستمر بل ومتصاعد خاصه بعد ان اعلنت
الجهات المعنيه عن نوايا جاده بايقاف بعض
البرامج التلفزيونيه وان القضاء يطالب
باستدعاء بعض صناع المحتوى المتواجدين
خارج العراق مصنفينهم كادوات لبث خطاب
الكراهيه وتهديد الدوله العراقيه بما
يقدمونه من موضوعات زينب المشهد صباح
العربيه بغداد